so now we're seeing conservative
protesters coming up
and doing something you know what we
mentioned this earlier in the show
that's
uh as far as i can tell rather
unprecedented at least
at least in this culture war that we've
seen the past several years first of all
when i started covering actually let me
make sure i give you guys the context
before i get into this
the independent reports protesters
attack police with pepper sprays they
try to storm oregon capital stories from
a couple days ago
two people arrested on charges of
trespassing and assaulting an officer
it was bear sprayed and these were
conservatives using bear spray against
police while entering the building
they say about 300 members of the proud
boys patriot prayer and other groups
arrived at the reopen oregon rally
calling on governor kate brown to lift
pandemic restrictions as lawmakers met
in a special session to discuss stimulus
and vaccination distribution measures
i've been covering this stuff since
2011. i've been
on the ground at protest since i was a
teenager going down in chicago to these
you know anti-iraq war stuff anti-afghan
work protests and just really
complaining all the time
and when i started covering uh occupy
wall street
i never saw a conservative protest you'd
see like tea party stuff
and you know that was i went to dc once
and i saw a bunch of lawn chairs
and it was a bunch of conservatives and
republicans waving little american flags
and i was like that's a protest yeah
well it was effective for them for sure
they they they played it smart they
played it better and meanwhile occupy
was very
physical you know non-violent civil
disobedience mixed with what they call
the diversity of tactics which really
sullied and sour the whole thing
but over the next several years we
started seeing you know proud boys come
out i remember going to berkeley
and seeing proud boys and it was like i
was i was like oh proud boys are out
here like they're just like you know
drinking with gavin and doing their
videos and now they're on the ground
now they were actually fighting with
antifa and
i remember i was in front of trump tower
and there was a trump supporter who's
just a
regular guy regular clothes and there
were protesters and i was talking to him
and he said he was a trump supporter and
i said why aren't you protesting why
aren't you coming out
and supporting your president and this
is years ago and he was like oh no no i
i
can't do anything like that so i
remember the first time i saw i think it
was in boston when i saw a march of
trump supporters chanting whose streets
our streets
and i laughed and i'm like that's what
the left says now you've got
conservatives organizing marching in
protests
i'll tell you what i haven't seen i have
seen antifa throw bricks at cops
throw molotovs at cops i've not seen
them pepper spray cops
certainly i think the molotovs are way
worse but it is it is
fascinating to me and i'm not saying
that in a good way i'm like
this is crazy to see conservatives bear
spraying cops
because you gotta really push the line
to make a conservative come after a cop
i mean these are these are people at
this protest there are a couple of
people waving thin blue live
thin blue line flags clearly in support
of police
now p someone there sprays the cops down
with bear mace
because these cops were barring them
from a hearing they were legally allowed
to enter
so windows got smashed cops shoved
people back a couple people got arrested
i'll tell you we do hear in the media a
lot fears about what the right will do
if they finally feel compressed and
they're going to push back and i'm like
it's a good point the problem is they
bring it up when no one no conservative
is doing anything
like antifa comes out burns down a whole
city and they're like but they're the
good guys they're fighting you know
fascism
and conservatives are walking around
with little american flags now
you have the the the very serious
question of if conservatives have
finally said
the these these officers who are
violating the constitution and keeping
us locked down and barring us from a
public hearing
if they're no longer on our side why
would it be on their side
but also it's also it's it's it's that
it's conservatives over the last year
have have have suffered just america has
suffered
uh but also conservatives are banned
conservatives
are canceled for the last four years
they they made
conservatives out to be conspiracy
theorists they called us
names deplorables chumps you name it
i mean every every conservatives are
constantly i mean look what
look at what antifa did
to elderly conservatives who
walked out of the republican national
convention and back to their hotels on
the last night in washington dc
this country has been under attack
under attack by the radical left for the
better part of a year
and conservatives have sat back and done
nothing but take it on the chin
every single month and so i i'm i
i'm not saying gosh i would like i don't
like violence
violence is unacceptable on either side
uh
but we are in the middle of i think the
greatest one of the greatest
constitutional one of the greatest
constitutional crisis
crises that we that we've ever
experienced in this country
conservatives already feel like they
don't have a voice this is what what's
happening
when when when free speech and the first
amendment is essentially canceled or
free speech is suppressed
bad things happen and in and part of the
i think that's part of what we're seeing
here today
you know those conservatives in oregon
you know got in the fight with the cops
out there
they were they were they were
unconstitutionally denied
their right to a public hearing they're
not violent they're they're not
certainly got some of them got violent
but it's very different from if a bunch
of like antifa people show up wearing
all black
they they typically act a fool and they
start threats and you say
take off your mask and hoodie in glasses
you can come in the building i'm fine
with that
if and if someone wants to protest and
come out yell rabble rabble and they
want to wear sunglasses a mask and a
hoodie
that's fine too you want to commit a
violent act that's not okay
but what's what's crazy now is antifa
fights cops
they fight cops we got that video as i
like seattle i think they threw a
molotov at cops that was that's crazy
i mean they're not just talking about
trying to kill the guy they're trying to
they're talking
when you throw a molotov at somebody
you're not just trying to commit murder
you want to make sure they suffer the
whole way through and if they survive
they they have
permanent injuries for the rest of their
lives that's psych that's psychotic
now conservatives who typically and
spent the whole year defending the
police
they're mad at him the police need the
support
of anybody they can get especially when
against the wishes of many of the
members of the public they're defunding
police
minnesota this is hilarious city council
votes to abolish their police department
all of a sudden crime rates start
skyrocketing locals are calling their
city council members saying what's
happening why aren't the police
responding to calls anymore
they come into an emergency meeting okay
we got to go backwards we want to do
over
this mistake it was a mistake they're
doing it even though people are saying
not to
and conservatives the whole time have
been saying back the blue
defend the police not defund the police
but what happens when the police don't
get that support because the police are
the ones now
so who are shutting down businesses
during the riots in june
antifa we're destroying small businesses
and burning down buildings
well now the videos i see in big cities
big cities they're democrat cities mind
you
it's the police doing it it's the nypd
who stood in front of that bar in staten
island
and and basically looked the guy in the
face and said you have no constitutional
rights because we say so
and they and will arrest you if you try
and let people into your building
you the first amendment says peaceably
assemble it doesn't say why
if i want to peaceably assemble to you
know play marbles or whatever i'm
allowed to do it
if someone says i'm gonna open up my
business i have a right you know i have
a right to open to the public
his constitutional right to publicly
assemble the police barred the building
who are those cops to fight the
constitution that way well i mean this
is part of this is part of the reason
why i say that you know the police
should
should not follow unconstitutional
orders they
they and and certainly in the
commonwealth of pennsylvania
we've not experienced i mean i've not
seen
i've not i've not seen or had
experiences like that in fact most of
the cops that i've come into contact
with
uh they loathe the orders in fact we've
had some sheriffs come out and say
simply we're not gonna we're not gonna
enforce them good they're
the government does not have a right to
deny your ability to make a living
the government does not have a right to
tell you what you have to wear
in your own house the government doesn't
have a right to tell you how many people
you can have in your own house so if
you're a police officer and you get a
call
and you know maybe a neighbor tells on
you tell us
you get a call and you show up to
someone's house and they got a couple
people in their house
you shouldn't you shouldn't be enforcing
unconstitutional orders
and and they're exactly they're orders
they're not laws
there's no statutory backing to this it
was some governor or mayo saying
mayor just saying do it and there are
cops who are doing it and also
can we also just have a conversation
about that like in pennsylvania
we're locked down again governor wolf
locked us down he shut down restaurants
and indoor dining
you know first of all there's absolutely
no science behind this right
and you're shutting down restaurants you
know what you know what happens when you
shut down restaurants if anything we
should be opening up
more restaurants to allow people to
spread out more but when people can't go
out
to a restaurant you know what they do
they entertain at home they go to their
friend's house they go to their friends
houses
so if you're looking for if you're
looking to stop the spread
of of covet 19 and you actually look at
some of the contract tracing research it
says 76 percent of the spread happens in
people's own home
what you're doing by closing restaurants
is is shunting people back into their
own homes
which according to your own research
allows for the spread of covet 19.
didn't the supreme court already ruled
that like the lock the first lockdown in
pennsylvania was the federal court the
federal court and then another judge
took it up and struck it down we've got
we've got so many so many experiences
with the court systems but
let me show you this from vox.com
december 10th southern california
sheriffs are refusing to
enforce stay-at-home orders
it's it's these big blue cities so
there's another reason why i'll always
say
the acab people are wrong somebody
commented i i so i i made a music video
uh in november and it's uh it's called
will the people you can check it out
but it's about the cycle of
authoritative and violence and someone
commented it was really funny they said
you made an entire video showing how the
bad guys
are the police and like the people are
rising up against them to remove the
dictators and
and they're always backed by the cops
and i'm like
when you when you have blue areas when
you have
democrats and the police there don't
care about the constitution
yes you have a problem when you have
these places in southern california
where the sheriffs uphold the
constitution
when you have places in smaller towns
and it's it's and local cops
who uphold the constitution the cops are
the good guys
the ones protecting you from the despots
from the authoritarians the greatest
hedge against authoritarianism is our
constitution
our constitution protects all americans
is a shield for
all americans against authoritarian
government
this is why uh my understanding is
most cops swear no to uphold the
constitution absolutely and they take it
seriously
and when they do they are literally the
good guys
when they don't they're literally bad
guys yeah police is a verb like if i
give you a gun i'm like go walk around
and make sure no one's out there you be
you're policing the area whether or not
you are adhered to the constitution has
nothing to do with it some of those guys
did take oh this and if they're
violating them that's a problem but
anyone can police
well it really does come down to cops as
the most important group of people and
i'm not saying important as a good or
bad thing
the most consequential group of people
in this country right now
are cops who are upholding their
constitution or breaking it in new york
we're seeing them break it
and that means people's lives are being
destroyed in areas like southern
california we're seeing them behold it
and they're the heroes
stopping the fa the the fascists well
i'll i have no problem calling them
use their own word against them these
these democrats that feel they have a
right to give our taxpayer dollars
to massive corporations to shut
everything down by edict
that's their fascists well and and then
when you see
some of the reporters talking to
governor wolf it it it really is
it would be hysterical if it weren't
tragic for these restaurants who are
closing in record numbers
in the state of pennsylvania reporters
asking him well
why are you closing restaurants what
what research are you using do you know
what he's saying he's like oh
well uh i i i can't think of
a more dangerous thing than people
sitting with me but but there's no
research to support
that that the spread of covet 19 is
happening in restaurants especially when
restaurants have invested tens of
thousands of dollars
in in taking 50 capacity people are
spread out they've got plexiglass or
they're outdoors
all your all you're effectively doing is
taking someone's ability to make a
living
three weeks before for before christmas
it's not just the owners of the
restaurants it's the busboys it's the
cooks it's the servers
all of these people are gonna have not
only trouble putting food on the table
for their family
but they're having they're going to have
issues
christmas for their children for god's
sake it's really really frustrating to
me so
i mean i've stood up in pennsylvania and
i feel like i'm the only one in
pennsylvania saying
restaurants stay open cops disobey
unconstitutional orders and it's working
except for now we've got government
government and health uh
the health department showing up to
restaurants and inside of one one
restaurant in western pennsylvania
giovanni's it's an italian restaurant
health department came in there and said
well you're not supposed to be open for
for in-person dining and he said well i
can't make a living if i if i don't so
they came back the next day they pulled
his health permit and they said oh we'll
make you a deal we'll let you do take
out he said i
i lose money when i do take out i'm
staying open he said well guess what we
got to shut you down now
how are they going to do it they well he
didn't listen so are they going to send
cops in
i don't i look if if they do i don't i
don't think i i
i don't know i hope that i hope that the
cops don't i hope that they don't comply
i don't think that they will
but but the point is people are starting
to push back and and what i said earlier
in the program
is a government derives power from the
consent of the people the moment we no
longer consent the government has no
power
to impose any unconstitutional lockdowns
and again
i'll say this again because there'll be
some radical left group that's going to
take this out of context and say that i
don't care about covet i do care about
covet a lot i think we need to adopt a
more
surgical pandemic response i think that
we can protect small businesses and
protect people's ability to make a
living while simultaneously protecting
public health i think we can do both
not only that i think at this point
i don't i don't care what the response
being offered up as long as it's not
locked down you know why we did the
lockdown didn't work
and the science behind them is dubious
at this point anybody that's advocating
for lockdowns at this point in the game
is not looking at the data and not
looking at it but but i'll clarify the
first point of the lockdowns was not to
stop
everyone from getting coveted it was to
make it so the hospitals could handle
the load by spreading it out
that was the goal of the lockdown we did
now it's back
we we slowed the spread it came back
with a vengeance we can't just do it
again because clearly it's just going to
keep coming back
we have to do something else so my
question is though with these protesters
at what point do conservatives
i don't know escalate as it were my my
there's a town called mossy brook in
washington where the mayor just said
we're exempt from the lockdown just by
his own decree
and so the city is just normal patriot
prayer you know right-wing groups showed
up
and they partied i'm i i think
you know people what the government is
doing is risking the loss of their
legitimacy
when you have police in new york and
other big cities violating the
constitution
well then people feel like the
government is illegitimate
when you have police officers who defy
the
the elected government like in southern
california to defend the constitution
then people are gonna start feeling like
their elected government is illegitimate
if the constitution is not being
protected or the or the the governors
are trying to
rip it apart then people are gonna lose
confidence at what point do we start
seeing
small towns and right-wing groups just
set up their own checkpoints or whatever
and say
you have no power here to like the cops
when they go hungry when they start
going hungry
god i hope that never happens i i think
we can avoid all of that by simply
disobeying the orders period
the most effective way because i this is
the most by the way by the way tim
like when i say disobey the orders i'm
simply saying restaurants stay open
small businesses stay open if you want
to leave your house and you want to go
shopping then go shopping follow cdc
guidelines wear a mask in the store
if you're if you're uh somebody that's
afraid of covid
right or if you're somebody that has a a
pre-existing condition
or if you're in a high-risk category you
know stay home order groceries online
look to your neighbor for help maybe
they'll go grocery shopping for you but
there are ways
human beings will find we will find a
way
to be safe and be responsible during all
this but
the point that i'm making is i don't
think a top-down
draconian government lockdown is the
answer because
you know there's that all afraid from
ronald reagan like uh i'm from the
government and i'm here to help
that scares me thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you
all next time